porque en estas regiones viven más
ciudadanos rusoparlantes que en el resto
del territorio ucraniano
bueno muchas gracias presentación en
primer lugar si efectivamente viven más
rusos pero viven solamente ahora esto no
fue la situación en el momento cuando
estos regiones intentaron a separarse
del territorio ucraniano de hecho
durante toda la historia de ucrania la
mayor parte de la población de estas
regiones no eran los rusos sino de los
ucranianos este es una región que pasó
por una historia muy compleja pero fue
poblado inicialmente por los cosacos de
la xix desaparecer y llamar parte de la
población que era predominantemente
rural eran los ucranianos en los finales
del siglo 19 el comienzo del siglo 20
comienza la industrialización de esta
región precisamente porque tiene muchos
recursos de carbón y están llegando los
rusos están llegando a los azerbayanos
están llegando a los belarusos entonces
esto es una región en ese entonces y al
momento de cuando ocurre la crisis de
2014 es una región multiétnica que es lo
que está pasando la mayor parte de la
población rusa vive en las ciudades y el
resto de la población que es
predominantemente ucraniana vive en las
zonas rurales la más o menos el rayo es
más o menos 60 casi 70 por ciento
dependiendo de los cordones y más o
menos 38 40 por ciento de los rusos la
población de estas región en ese
entonces era cerca de 4 millones de
habitantes hoy en día es más o menos
cerca de 2 millones de habitantes o
incluso menos y lo que pasa que son 90
95 por ciento de la población urbana y
el resto en zonas rurales qué significa
que la mayor parte de los ucranianos
simplemente fue expulsada de estos mary
que juanes durante todos los eventos que
pasaron después de 2014 entonces sería
equivocado hablar que es una región rusa
en este sentido claro señor rubinsky
entonces a qué se puede deber la
independencia o el apoyo a la
independencia en 2014 había un apoyo
masivo o realmente tiene más que ver con
la fuerza política y militar de los pro
rusos
y yo no creo que existe un apoyo por lo
menos no existe un apoyo de tal manera
que existía en crimea en 2014 cuando
claramente la mayor parte de los
habitantes de cree me estuvieron
apoyando la idea con la unión con rusia
hay que prestar la atención a algo que
está pasando en este momento lo que pasa
que los separatistas estas fuerzas
prorrusas
efectivamente apoyado en por lomos por
moscú recordamos que uno de los líderes
de esos movimientos era un oficial del
servicio activo de inteligencia rusa
entonces ellos controlan sólo una parte
de lo que eran las regiones de donets
colo guns y lo que dijo vladimir putin
ahora que la tarea debe estar controlar
toda la región pero no toda la parte de
donde a descolgarse apoyaron los
separatistas entonces yo no creo que
existe un apoyo masivo porque además
estos dos regiones no son las
democracias son regímenes autoritarios
entonces no sabemos realmente cuáles son
los hechos reales listos señor rubinsky
entonces brevemente según el derecho
internacional
qué dice derecho internacional sobre el
reconocimiento de las repúblicas y le
daría derecho a rusia a una hipotética
anexión no para nada lo que pasa es que
las naciones sonidos ahora dijeron que
esto fue contra la ley internacional
completamente claramente que cada país
tiene derecho legítimo de reconocer a
otro país pero tiene que ver con también
el derecho internacional si no tenemos
un causa en el mundo y en este sentido
yo creo que vladimir putin se siente muy
incómodo porque las voces que le están
apoyando son muy pocos así y sobre todo
porque no sabemos si realmente la
población de estas regiones está tanto a
favor a rusia o no porque no tenemos
forma de comprobarlo